the success was the progressive
realisation of a worthy ideal anyone
that has a goal and they're moving
towards it they're successful most
people think that you're successful if
you have a lot of money quite often you
have a lot of money if you're successful
but it isn't
I wouldn't say mother Teresa has a lot
of money okay huh but she's a pretty
successful lady I think there's two
barriers one is our conditioning the
conditioning that takes place in our
subconscious mind from the time were
infants all we can do is act and talk
like the people around us that's why we
learn their language we learned we have
a real strong conditioning usually with
not some very good ideas and then that
that's the the barrier that's inside is
the one that's outside of us as our
environment we have a tendency to act
like everybody around us and if you
think about this it doesn't make a lot
of sense because if you study statistics
95 percent of the people live their
entire life and never lived the way they
want to live my 5% of the people end up
financially comfortable or independent
we all think different thoughts and I
believe we should start to think and
build images in our mind of what we'd
like to do and then set out and do it
you should seek failures see if you're
playing it safe you're not gonna win if
you're playing it safe like that all say
you know you were topping your little
girl better to be safe than sorry well
that's a bunch of crap it's not better
be safe than sorry it's by trying things
that you figure out how far you can go
you've got to get outside the box it
Edison tried 3000 ways before he built
the incandescent light he said he didn't
deal 3,000 times he said there was 3000
different steps to building a lightbulb
well there's different steps to get to
where you're going and I really do treat
winning and losing exactly the same I do
not let it upset me I'll try anything
like if if I'm into an idea the idea of
losing never enters my mind and if
you're not prepared to lose you're never
gonna win
because you're always playing it safe oh
there's no reward mad you just watched
two amazing clips from Bob Proctor take
the next three minutes to sit quietly
and think about how you can apply them
to your business and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]